un jour la vie 21 déserté la terre
elle était née bruno plongèrent
au fond de la vis
stephen hawking disait
dans le futur si l'espèce humaine veut
survivre elle devra quitter la planète
terre
[Musique]
à des années lumière de notre monde
nous allons créer un nouveau foyer pour
l'humanité
un exode vers la terre promise
[Musique]
la planète est réuni toutes les
conditions pour abriter la vie
préparez vous au choc
les cartes stellaire elles ne
correspondent pas nous ne sommes pas sur
tech
objet non identifié en approche
vous ne pouvez pas rester ici
devons aller au cours de la mission
évacué rebbah tués
une nouvelle page de notre histoire
commence ici